hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a keynote presentation
and katz automation capabilities where
we are and where we are going it is
presented by Sam Michael the director of
automation on and compound management at
the National Center for advancing
translational sciences and cats at the
National Institutes of Health I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming Sam
Michael I will now turn the presentation
over to him
Judy and lab reads thank you for the
opportunity to give this presentation
which is MCATs automation capabilities
where we are and where we are going I
wanted to start with the history of how
MCATs was formed we originally started
in 2004 as part of the NIH roadmap for
molecular libraries initiative which was
dubbed the ml PCN and part of this was
to actually develop new chemical probes
for basic research and leads for
therapeutic development particularly for
a neglected diseases and even though we
started that in 2004 we really continue
that tradition to this day also part of
our mission was to make sure that we had
new paradigms and applications of HTS
for chemical biology and chemical
genomics we were part of NHGRI up until
January of 2012 actually with the
Affordable Care Act and passed into law
was officially on cats birthday so
December 23rd 2011 is when we became n
cats who are now a center within NIH so
part of our focus has always been with
steps in the drug development process
and where we reside at n cats is really
primarily with the translational piece
of our Institute not so much the target
identity which is the basic research
side but more from the assay development
up to preclinical development this is
more in the intramural side the
extramural part goes further on to the
actual clinical that's the CTSA program
clinical translation science award the
focus of this talk is going to be more
along the lines of the intramural
program which is really focused on acid
development through medicinal chemistry
at which point typically we had projects
over and so part of this and part of the
reason for the form of a foundation of n
cats is this this concept of the drug
development valley of death if you look
from that same chart who will leave the
clinical it is that the chance of
success goes very far down and the cost
goes exponentially up and it's a little
too risky for commercial entities
invest in this space and so part of the
mission of n Katz was to try especially
three diseases to bridge this gap to
take promising leads de-risk them by
putting some science behind them in
validating that there's actually
something of substance there and hand
this over to a potential partner and
collaborator who can then carry this
forward to a clinical IND and we've had
some success in that so a core portion
of this of what we do in MCATs and
really geared towards the automation is
what we call quantitive HTS or cue HTS
and so one of the paradigms that was
well established at n cats are early on
from some of the founders who have done
plenty of screening you know all of our
industry and primarily at Merck is is
the concept of not screening at a single
point and so we actually screened at any
cats as we screen at a dose-response and
which is important to note is we don't
just screen the single concentration we
actually generate those response curve
for every Ashley we run so what's
interesting from an automation
perspective is this has been well
established and on the slide you can see
several classes when we're considering
class four which is in fact no activity
to class one was a very potent activity
and all of this code these
classifications are available to the
public but what we realized is from the
automation perspective this made it
challenging
so for perspective if our compound
library is two hundred thousand
compounds but I screen at five dose
responses Benz equivalent to a million
compound library so we need a high
degree of automation which we invested
in early on going back to 2005 and you
continue to invest and so when you're
looking at these systems here the one on
the right is our primary system we first
got established from GM F the genomics
Institute or at Novartis Foundation
going back to 2005 and this has been our
workhorse system still in use to this
day and it's a much more early
generation you'll see in a moment with
the video large robotic arms and then
the system on the left is a smaller
version of that that we have for a
specific program called the tox train
one screening system you can see the
capacity we can run seven several
thousand plates hold them at a time
we can run the millions of wells we
really have a high degree of automated
capabilities but I wanna see these are
legacy systems but this is a little bit
of where we were we're still here but
what are we going to advance to is the
focus of this this presentation and then
if you want to see the video now for the
high throughput screening system in
action this is you'll be in to see these
arms moving plates from station to
station
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so what she saw there was the
robotic system of moving plates from
point A to point B and really these arms
are very industrial and that was partly
the change in the early 2000s because
one of the biggest failure points of
high-throughput screening in the 90s was
actually guaranteed plate delivery and
these is something that when they switch
to these industrial arms that you
actually had a high degree of
reliability to ensure that if you wanted
to move from station the station for
plate it would actually occur and these
arms have been incredibly successful in
what we tasked them to do since we
started with many of the assays and the
high-throughput screening system we've
also since really established a program
at MCATs for drug repurposing and
combination discovery and we've had so
much demand for this that we've recently
a couple years ago now have incorporated
a smaller skin simply digest acoustic
transfer we actually have another device
we've just got which is a lab sight
system we have both EDC's and lab sights
our variety reasons here the focus the
EDC is the most raw molecule the folks
the lab sites has more biologics but
this system is an example of what we're
looking at here you can notice one of
the primary differences between this and
the previous video is this system is
open there's really no need for
gardening because they sense change the
robotic arms from those large industrial
arms and all the safety requirements to
these direct drive arms which are much
more user-friendly and you can see on
the image on the right where it says one
robotic arm it's actually a track so you
get a fair amount of range of Musha of
motion from that actual arm without the
safety considerations and part of this
is also our methodology of any cats and
something to consider of how you can
modular eyes a process and what I mean
by that is you want to actually separate
the process from different steps
potentially you don't need to automate
everything so if I just need to produce
a large amount of combination plates
they don't get to that a second I don't
need that all on the same system I can
have a separate system work and
they're fashioned to produce those
plates act as an input and so what we're
doing here instead of very large
compound libraries is we actually have a
small targeted library this has been
published on and mic stands for the
mechanism interrogation plate it sends
expanded from one plate to actual a
couple thousand compounds and we run
these in combination to look for
therapeutics really geared towards
oncology and very cell based assays here
and so what this looks like is instead
of having a single point or a single
dose response curve we actually run in
combination to competing those response
curves for two of these drugs we've
actually done three drug combinations
and what we're really looking for here
is the synergy and so this is another
example of some of the challenges that
we're facing at end Katz's we have to
support the legacy projects which are
with their traditional chemical library
and then as we expand its new biological
space and new assay needs our automation
has to account for that and so part of
our model has been to modularize what
system performs what tasks so not all
burden gets put on one system even
though it's capable of pulling it off
and so let's give an example to describe
how these schedulers work how these
systems work and how you can actually
manipulate them to actually do more
complex assays but also take a step
further from automata mating something
and actually with the goal towards
eventual autonomy and so here's a very
basic enzyme makes an enzyme activity a
say is you have enzyme and substrate in
the presence of a compound they incubate
and they produce a product to that
product you add a potential reagent you
bring that plate with all those
reactions taking place and you do a
luminescence read to measure what that
activity is and this is just from a
workflow perspective and so as
everyone's well aware of in this
industry most of all the reactions take
place and in a micro well plate now for
the ml piece yet and given that the m/l
s/m are the size of the collection by
the end of it which was several hundred
thousand compounds we decided to
miniaturize to 1536 well plates and a
lot of our automation is geared towards
that what's very interesting is we get
more complex biological systems with
regards to 3d spheroids and even tissue
printing type initiatives is the density
of the well plates actually going
opposite or don't work we're doing 1536
we're doing a lot more 384 some 96 we're
even doing some 24 well plates depending
upon the actual complexity of the
structure but the well plate still
remains the workhorse of where all of
these reactions take place so if I look
at this system and is a series of
devices you can consider this as the
overall peripherals that control how
what methods you're able to run meaning
what what steps you can perform your
assay plate and what kind of experiments
that you want to have everything from
reagent addition and dispensers the
compound addition being a Pinto or an
acoustic transfer device and to a
variety of plate readers even looking at
this overlay here is having a modular
system is very helpful
we've sense to actually have a fair
estar in this system we have a ha
moments we have the SS we've taken the
multi drops off there's a lot you can do
to reconfigure these systems and I think
that's a key when you're considering
what sort of automation you should be
looking for but also to have that
flexibility that lets you think about
experiments that you haven't even
thought about when you first purchase
these systems another important point is
not only the system devices but to
consider these overall systems as for
what they really are it's it's its own
independent subnet and so this is the
network diagram showing that effectively
one thing we see for not just us at n
cats but many folks is is tcp/ip is
ubiquitous at this point there's still
some serial devices in the random you
know Ethernet IP and so on and so forth
but by and large is most of these
devices have a direct Ethernet
connection so you can envision this as
an actual network device and that's a
really important thing to consider
because if you have a networked device
with a subnet of the individual
components but those components can
access the primary system controller you
can actually have a higher level of
control over your entire system and your
system itself doesn't have to be
isolated it can actually communicate
with the external applications or in
many cases now with the prevalence of
cloud based computing actually if you
automate an analysis and spawn new
experiments and we'll get to that in a
few minutes but it's really important to
recognize that these systems now are
really a part of a network and so if we
want to run an experiment Dyne I
described
prior and and what is our HTS scheduling
methodology now we adopted much of this
from the original gmf system which is
the one that we showed prior the the
tried and true and so if you have the
plates and the beep that the assay
plates act as the input to our HTS
system and may have associated control
and compound plates is required because
you have to get the compounds into the
assay plate if you consider each assay
plate to be an assay object a method is
the set of steps each assay object will
run with each step usually associated
with some peripheral device be it for
example dispenses reagent at this time
so a group of asset objects running the
same method is considered to be an assay
and we said with a capital A that's what
we consider that a collection of these
objects comprise one assay with the
system we have you can run multiple
assays at the same time and that's
because the scheduling methodology we
have is what we call a wait queue and a
mutex and so how does this work and so
at the start of an assay all assay
objects are placed in the first-in
first-out wait cubes this is a FIFO very
well established technique a way to use
a queue of objects waiting for a lock
which in this case represents controlled
a peripheral device on the screening
system when the lock is unlocked the
objects acquire the lock in the order of
the queue
getting back to the FIFO the first one
in is the first one to release the lock
so what this will look like is if for
example that meant that I gave and from
this diagram here as you see that
there's an unlock there right by that
flask which will represent a dispenser
the first plates the bottom plate in
this case of the stack will actually go
and what I'll do is since it's unlocked
it will build that device and then it
will actually lock the device so the
plate that's waiting for it cannot have
access until it's done with that step
once it actually performs the dispensed
and moves to the next step in this case
is a read is the mutex flow dispenser
unlock
and the next plate is free to go through
and so objects still in the queue in a
block state until the lock is released
so if you look at this now the second
plate can't go to the reader because the
first plate still in the read step if we
progress that through and the last plate
goes to be discarded it unlocks the
reader at which point the second plate
can actually get read and they can
complete its process and so each step or
a series of linked steps in a method has
an associative lock and this type of
synchronization being called a mutex for
mutual exclusion which pretty much means
if something has the lock another device
can access it and as simple as this
scheduling is it's unbelievably powerful
because you can control to the device
level and the assay plate level every
single event that occurs and when it
occurs and so we'll give some examples
of what we've done that cats with this
but I really can't stress the point that
this is a very powerful scheduling
methodology that gives you flexibility
when they higher-level application if
you choose to take advantage of it
and so from this perspective if you have
a traditionally chef's workflow what
does it look like you'll set up your
system you'll note all the plates and
reagents you'll run the assay protocol
for each plate key point there's a
one-to-one relationship between assay
plates the compound plates now you
remember that we screen at a
dose-response meaning we have a set of
inter plate compound plates that are
there so say if I have for assay plates
each one of those will be for compound
plates where the compounds of the same
but the concentration is what buries and
their traditional workflow is you just
run each series at a time at the start
of the assay and then eventually it'll
run to completion and then if you look
at this again from a workflow
perspective this is the overlay of our
system this is showing what one Gantt
chart representation would look like a
variety of the actual steps that would
occur so you actually have the enzyme
being dispensed first at one of the
dispensers we have the compound the pen
tool the substrate is to spend
subsequently they incubate an incubator
and that produces the product so on and
so forth and this is what it looks like
represented with a one spending plate we
the assay plate and the compound plate
acting as inputs now if you look at this
as a Gantt chart this is what 20 plates
look like and what you can see from this
Gantt chart for 20 plates is these
plates ran really nice and they ran nice
and parallel the parallel lines and you
can see with the rate-limiting stamping
the first enzyme dispensed and nice
steady flow of how these 20 plates ran
it was more than 20 plates it's just one
window into this and all of this is
tracked and saved in real time so we
actually have a web-based system where
we can look at the assay performance so
we can see how the assay is performing
as it goes along so here there's a
couple uh a couple of points I want to
make about what makes is possible
especially 1536 and something that
really gets overlooked and I think G and
that should get tremendous credit for is
one of the key changes they made is what
we joke around too is the kungfu grip
but when we mentioned that in the past
part of the challenge with the the plate
failures for high-throughput screening
was dropping plates and not having this
lagina actually because they did was
they designed a play transportation
system meaning they made a mechanical
solution with this flange in this
distill joint between the gripper and
the flange of the plate and that really
gives this gripper an absolutely secure
lock on this plate for placement so if
you consider the math of what MCATs does
here we're typically over nine hundred
thousand moves a year meaning a specific
movable plate from one location to
another and we have multiple of these
arms without failure and that's really
impressive and so you know there's all
the software in the world all the fancy
experiments don't mean anything if you
can't have that guaranteed packet
delivery as we call that from that
networking socket is this is a really
nice piece of mechanism they made here
the next step is you put a lid on it
meaning you have 1536 how do you prevent
evaporation a common technique now used
as well as a sealing peel model many
people have played cos many people have
the xpl amount very fantastic device
that just works like a champ
so you really have to prevent
evaporation especially with some of the
longer cell based assays where sealing
isn't quite an option all there are
permeable seals but they don't work as
well and so some of this is just to give
a foundation of this
you have a stable platform like this
what can you do with it and how can you
expand upon this so many of these
systems you have the capability of
monitoring events and then you know to
see what they're doing but do you
actually have the ability to
programmatically control molesville
assays running at the same time and the
scheduling software that we have allows
for that since we can actually create
custom triggers and then those trigger
events can actually fire some process to
happen so let's give an example of this
and this is just showing the monitoring
technique is we have an entire system
running what it creates is the data from
the plate reads which are saved
automatically to informatics and now we
actually save those to a cloud-based
environment as well and then we have a
controlling application that can in fact
act as the overall listener to spawn new
experiments so we can programmatically
launch experiments based upon the
results of an experiment running on the
system this is important because as more
and more folks get involved in
phenotypic screening and some of these
more you know agnostic type approaches
you actually and when you hear in the
buzz words of machine learning and deep
learning what does that really mean well
if you have a screening system that's
set up now that actually can take
external input to create and launch a
new experiment it becomes a pretty
powerful tool but but how do we actually
get this done what's the programming
what's the methodology behind this and
so we've decided what we program that
end Katz's is we really set up three
distinct event types you can do them on
a per plate meaning on one plate we'll
have what we call the transition step
index meaning a particular step of a
method is actually in a position that it
can get we can set an event that would
that index occurs or that step of the
method execute it can spawn another
process or spawn some event we can do
this basic on a per group meaning a
group of plates when they're complete
something else happens or we can have an
external application completely control
our system as if it just receives an
input assuming the appropriate inputs
are there and so what are some of the
examples here what we want to focus on -
when I focus on the QC process and also
how we initiate a new assay and why
and so this is where we're also talking
about how we increase the level of
control that we have at M cats and the
rationale why and so one of the first
things that we ran into with the tox 21
robot is they were doing quite a bit of
beta lactamase assays and the CCF would
die as a percent DMSO on a valve based
dispenser the bio raptor the challenge
with this approach is that's really
prone to clogging and so what you're
seeing here is the the four tips of the
clogged of beta lactamase reagent now
the reason this was so catastrophic
would have happened if I were to wait to
the read step to see that this dispensed
didn't happen the read step is after a
two-hour boot camp incubate and my
throughput of plates is about 16 to 20
plates an hour I may have lost 32 plates
before I can capture that this this
dispensed problem has happened so I had
to catch this in real time and so how do
we do this and so what we ended up
setting up is we have a series of
sensors and four sensors working in
parallel that are retro-reflective and
so every time a droplet intersects the
beam if you considered a through beam
type approach it can actually trigger a
response and then if I have a simple I
ho module I can actually capture every
single dispense as it happens and if
I've launched that over time but I end
up creating as a digital wave form for
each tip and what I'm expecting is if I
expect that he one microliter dispense I
shouldn't even count every single
droplet for that dispense as it's
occurring and so how do we validate this
is it be look at this with these valve
based dispensers is it's what they call
a spike and hold circuit and so the
spike voltage is what actually actuates
are open the valves and you only need
that momentarily and then if you look at
that the hole voltage is to keep that
actuator open once the actuator is held
open the period of time it's open is
what dictates and you calibrate this is
what the dispense is and so if you look
at this trace the yellow trace is the
whole circuit the green is the spike the
body cyan color is what the sensor is
reading in response and you can see for
one microliter dispensed it's about 8
and 1/2 milliseconds of open time and
the sensors measuring that it saw about
8 and 1/2 milliseconds worth of actually
with dispensed so we showed that we can
monitor this the five Michael your exact
same principle the only difference is
you see the valve open time is actually
extended from eight to about 30
microseconds so what we ended up or
milliseconds I'm sorry well we ended up
doing is we created a bioreactor fixture
and what you're seeing the bottom right
is you see that tip array which the
bioreactor instead of the traditional
nine to nine nine millimeter tip the tip
spacing did this sort of clot approach
which is a little more difficult but
when you can see is we were able to make
a fixture that can do cross-sections and
actually monitor all four tips
simultaneously and so what that allowed
us to do is actually monitor in real
time and count the number of droplets
and so if you watch these two videos
back-to-back is if you play these side
by side is what you'll see in the
software screen on the left is get
counting every individual peak and what
you'll see on the right is what that
looked like on the actual dispenser
itself if you show those videos
you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the Black Plague definitely over
[Music]
don't forget the what's wrong yep
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
and so what we ended up doing with this
drop of detection because it was very
important for us and one thing we do
with any cats is we actually like to
disseminate what we do once we
demonstrated it is is we actually create
an SBIR and two awards were issued for
this and then the real reason is now
that the play transportation problem has
been solved the real limitation is the
actual dispense here has really caused a
bunch of problems and then this was also
the final missing step of data integrity
chain to validate the dispense actually
took place and not necessarily at the
plate level only but the tip level
itself and a big part of this too is
conservation of reagent it's not just
the loss of the experiment having to
rerun it a lot of these reagents are
really expensive we ran into a problem
though is the bio Raptors discontinued
and this originally from Aurora and then
it sold to Backman and then even though
our biologists here love the bio Raptors
they're no longer available so what we
decided to do is we want to build our
own dispenser with the same criteria and
we decided in this case focus our
platform around the mecca 500 robot as
the really dispenser platform and this
gets the going forward instead of a
monolithic system having a more modular
approach why don't we pick the Makah 500
so if you look at this picture here on
the left you can actually see someone
holding this robot that's the actual
size it's a tiny little six axis arm and
what that gives us is the flexibility to
actually do a lot of things that a
traditional XY dispenser can't do it has
five micron repeatability there's no
external controller and a direct tcp/ip
Ethernet connection and can meet all the
criteria for bio raptor the other real
key point about this is if I have the
six axis arm grab a plate and that plate
acts as the foundation if I don't need
to actually have a stacker and a
dispenser because the robot arm is the
stacker and the dispenser in one and
what does this mean if you look at this
image here is if you see this is what
you'll see is this is our setup that we
have when we have an input stack and an
output stack and then you can see our
bank of dispensers there in the
background in the middle of the image
there with the angle and it actually has
dropped with attach and integrate
you
and when she saw there was the the
dispenser the robot acting is the
dispenser and the stacker and one and
part of the reason aside from the
footprint we wanted to focus on that as
we consider the cost and let's give you
perspective is a by our after back in
the day would cost $90,000 even the day
you had a multi drop that cost you about
twenty thousand depending upon twenty
three really they keep on going up in
price if you want to buy a stack our on
that you're talking about an additional
fifteen to twenty thousand dollars it
really depends upon the stacker so
you're committed to forty thousand
dollars for just a basic dispenser or
considered some of their equivalent ones
not like the bio raptor if i combine
those two and the total hardware cost
for everything you just saw there
between the robot arm and all the valves
and whatnot is around sixteen thousand
dollars that's a pretty substantial cost
savings that you can actually make and
actually have a very reliable device um
let's talk about another event type we
can monitor and the reason why for this
is if when we describe the actual
process of adding a say two uh reagent
to an assay plate transferring the
compound adding a detection region and
then actually taking an image of this
plate to do a measurement if you know
the difference is instead of trashing
the plate from before what if we can
actually clean this assay plate and
reuse it so the first step is we did two
experiment we did wash this back notice
or absorption and for fluorescence and
we did an experiment we really spiked
BSA to one percent and we want to
measure if we can clean that out of this
plate just using a spray techniques
everything from a suck-ass breeder or
actually to a center for the centrifuge
type technique and then doing
intermediate wash steps with 70 percent
ethanol and water and we can see from
the actual chart here from the actual
plate is is almost completely removed
and so it showed us that we could
actually fluorescence as well we can
really clean and reuse these plates and
that gives us a thought is in we don't
have to throw these plates away and set
up an individual plate for every
compound plate you want to run is it
really gives you flexibility let's start
thinking about these systems is a
continuous process and not just a batch
mode type approach and so the first step
is how do I determine the actual assay
plate buffer size and that's the total
last iteration divided by the rate of
plate addition and this is there's more
complexity you can answer this but
by-and-large
is if I run a run a thousand plate a say
I don't have a thousand assay plates on
the system at a time I only have that
number of plates which are currently
undergoing some step and so if you
determine that buffer size what you can
end up creating is a circular buffer and
so what you can do is with two series
equates one full cycle is if I extract
from the head of my buffer and then
insert plates into the tail is I can
have a continuous process that runs
without interruption by using far fewer
plates and some of my step is that I
have a buffer size in the example I gave
and we need about eleven plates at a
time I can only use twenty-two plates
and I can run however many compound
plates I actually want to you know get
through and so what this looks like if
you change the workflow if you remember
prior is now the first set of plates
will go and they'll get run against the
compound plate the second set of plates
will go and they'll run against their
compound plates but instead of the third
set of plates running is the first set
of plates will run again and then the
second set of plates will run again and
this process will continue up until the
point that the actual assay is complete
and so what does this look like from a
Gantt chart perspective this is an
example of a very complex but slow
movement assay where this assay ran for
seven straight days with two assays in
parallel and all that had to be done was
just top off the reagents and this is a
tremendous savings of resources both
from time spent loading up a thousand
plates and then throwing a thousand
plates away and also saving all of that
plastic if I could run over a thousand
plates with 44 plates I saved over 900
plays another example here is what this
looks like with one single arras a more
traditional enzymatic and also from a
conformation perspective is if we ran
over 400,000 compounds and for
continuous days just by topping off the
actual reagents is what was the con for
me
raid from this assay we actually had 529
compound selected 504 confirmed on the
actual follow-up it's 90 percent 95
percent confirmation rate which is
really fantastic
um and so part of the reason and another
example people ask is you know will you
miss anything with this and we want to
even example of this LDH a project in
this case if you look at the hip over
here in the yellow and the bottom it
wasn't that high concentration all these
plates were washed and so every there
was 40 plates used and each for each
plate was used 38 times and we were
still able to whittle out the primary
lead which two rounds of met came in we
actually had a very potent compounds you
can see in the chart in the bottom so
the bottom line is you can actually
adopt this approach and not impact your
science and then the question in this
case is you know why is that cats
involved and this is really a huge part
is aside from the reducing the set-up
time and running this is a long-standing
continuous process and remember that
when we talk about eventually making
things autonomous you have to show your
system can run continuously because
we've saved over half a million dollars
in plastic and not to mention barrels
and barrels and barrels of things
handing off into a landfill somewhere or
incinerated and so this also led to an
SBIR contract and part of the reason we
wanted this is we're cleaning it but for
cell baseplates as this was really for
biochemical you really don't have this
continuous process because many of the
cell based experiments are endpoint
reads so we use this SBIR and ion field
end up winning and their technology
their plasmas they call it their tip
charger systems as if you imagine it
oxidizes the surface and actually breaks
up organic compounds and just releases
this as a gas state so with ventilation
and so part of the reason we want to do
this is the estimate you can see in this
industry we use a hundred twenty five
million plates per year and so you put
those end-to-end that's close to 10,000
miles in plates every year that we're
using and if you're actually map that
out that's actually from Washington DC
to Melbourne Australia is how many
plates is really fascinating an article
that came out in The Guardian not too
long ago that there's enough plastic
that it can actually exist in the fossil
record
and you can see from this blurb here 300
million tons of class a year and
typically most plastic is used you know
once and then thrown away and in our
industry it's much more than that so
part of the reason as well was this
focus and cell based assays and this is
just showing as well that the plates
that come in aren't necessarily all of
that clean there's actually contaminants
on the plates as you get them but can we
actually show the effectiveness of
cleaning a cell based plate so what
we're seeing here cells and we're doing
a cell tighter globe lead here the plate
on the top was actually run on December
17th of 2015 what you're seeing with a
green highlighted box is that's what the
controls were and that was bortezomib
which is very cytotoxic in columns 2 & 3
column 1 is no cell the same plate was
rerun on january 14th in 2016 and you
can see those cells that went from a
total kill once it was actually cleaned
and cells were receded and incubated
again you couldn't tell the difference
between the use plate and a clean plate
so this is really showing that you can
actually get these results without
really impacting your science at all
which is first and foremost is you don't
want to introduce another variable um
why were we this this focus on all of
the cell de screening the real issue
that we're running into are not issue is
we've done a real shift from biochemical
assays to cell based assays for a
variety of reasons just the acetate
types were doing and that leads to a
large amount of cell production which
can run into problems and this was
another area that we decided that we
want to automate and so we started
introducing and we purchased our first
compound select e where flasks and media
go in and what the output is there
either flask the cells that people can
prep or actually a plate incubator where
you can actually play these cells and
have those plates ready to go so back to
this workflow model if we were to
envision this again is if I have flax
and Culture Media in and the output of
1536 well played how can I get that well
played from the Select e to one of our
screening systems and so it can
essentially what we thought is somewhat
facetiously at first as we said well
what if he's a drum you know we
we had these two separate systems that
were about 15 feet apart and it would
really be straightforward if the cell
system can send a message I have a plate
ready for me and deliver that that would
really be something fantastic so we took
this on and we said okay but with this
objective for this project B and it
really is is autonomously move a plate
from one location to another
and in this case would be the Select e
letting it know through an event that
has produced a cell plate and it's ready
and then for that to trigger an external
event for this drone to go and pick it
up and then to bring that over to our
high-throughput screening system and
land it and remember some of this was
just conceptual but we want to see the
technical challenges of what it would
take to really have autonomous not just
from an informatics perspective but
actually from a mechanical screening
perspective is this conceptually
feasible and so what were the components
we would need we need a drone we need
the gripper assembly and we need a
charging station because part of what we
decided is this drone would actually
have to be recharged in between flights
and maybe it's not one drone maybe it's
a fleet of drones a lot of actual
software out there already available for
flight mapping and so the conceptual
work flow would be imagine you have a
wall mounting recharging station it
would get the command to pick it up from
a location what we're showing here and
this this graphic on the right is coming
from an old centrifuge pick it up from
the centrifuge and then put it into an
actual hotel and plates here and we
picked this for conceptionally a
challenge to make this difficult and
then return back once it's dropped off
to its base station and so the first
drone we picked we picked the matrix 100
because it was a supposedly open
platform and also it had the ability to
add the Odroid onboard computer and it
had a guidance module you can
incorporate we know we needed more than
just the onboard drone computer we also
need some system for indoor navigation
at which point that way actually focused
on bike on where you can actually set up
cameras and what you're seeing in this
top right display is where it shows the
software in the visualization of how
it's mapping the area it's a little bit
of a inverse logic here the areas in the
orange are really what are showing that
it has a lot of positional accuracy the
outer edge in the green
is where it just doesn't have as much
but in that center area if you look at
that work on envelope you can actually
see it's pretty big if you compare that
work envelope compared to that of a
robot with a base station which is in
place you actually have a lot of
flexibility all of this software does is
these four cameras it just streams
multiple drone locations as tcp/ip data
as a position vector which makes it
really powerful and if you look at this
next video that's showing up is what
this will show is the ability for you to
track multiple drones at the same time
you
digital representation so once we got
that set up we also decided in parallel
to actually try to do the drone
recharging there's a company called sky
sense which has been actually doing this
and they've commercialize this so this
already exists what you're looking at is
our matrix 100 on the sky sense platform
on the right there is you'll actually
see the two electrodes touching the
surface one important point to make is
these platforms are they are constantly
charged is it's once the drone with a
particular key actually lands and makes
contact that's when the charging begins
what you're looking at the bottom right
there is just showing that the current
switch is from high current to very low
current and ocher and once it recharges
the battery we had this battery
completely dead and it took an hour and
20 minutes but that's assuming that the
drones lifetime is 20 to 30 minutes we
really don't need that long to drop off
a plate so realistically you would be in
the not too long to recharge this but
there was really some problems with the
matrix 100 it was just too big for
indoor flight and it really wasn't safe
and it wasn't conducive the rotor wash
was so powerful it actually just had a
lot of variables that even with a good
control system we couldn't maintain so
we decided instead to do a proof of
concept is how do we have a parrot drone
which is a $200 drone if not cheaper
take the actual shielding off there and
introduce a gripper with this the
challenge we had with introducing a
gripper even with low level control is
it really adjusts the center of mass and
as this video will show is when the
drone takes off it should go straight up
and I think you'll see it doesn't go
just straight up here
I think when you saw in that video is
when you saw it take off is we couldn't
control at the root level of the actual
firmware how to accommodate for the
center of mass difference and that's
where you saw it actually had that wild
swing forward and then part of me did
notice is over time though it was able
to overcome and compensate at which
point we can move the drone around
accurately and then actually land it
pretty precisely even just with the
vikon cameras which you saw there you
know you can see the tripod in the back
and we have four of these cameras what
we decided to prove this conceptually
was let's just do an electromagnet and
pick up a washer to show we can do a
pick in place that it's conceptually
feasible with the drone that we could
pull this off and maybe if we're
successful we could issue an SBIR and so
the system components for this were the
controlling software that has the vikon
cameras and the associate and data that
it streams and then we have our own
custom abun to our ross operating system
app that we developed that communicates
with the drone and gets positions from
the feet of the vikon to feedback to the
drone to move to positions that we pre
defined with the vikon camera system in
the fiducial marks and so what were able
to show once we did that is we were
actually able to do a successful pic in
place of a washer of picking up a washer
so you'll see the drone descend over to
one table and what it's doing there with
the electromagnet is picking up a
metallic washer flying to another
station and then dropping that off if
you watch this video
sort of successful and successful enough
that we figured we could do an SBIR to
actually see what the response would be
and there was actually tremendous I
think this was one of the SBIR is that
we issued an end cats that we receive
the most responses ever and ended up
meeting or we awarded three phase one
proposals and we wanted to actually see
if someone could meet this challenge
with this autonomous pickup and delivery
of an actual plate if you can actually
incorporate the low-level design and so
as an example one of the awardees was
actually able to come up with their own
custom canted rotor hex copter for all
the stability issues that you saw in
some of those videos is this provides
six degrees of freedom control in
translating XY plane on maintaining
level altitude and and and really what
that means in this case is there's no
picture at all when it moves and the
total weight of this drone is about 2.1
kilograms and it's actually has room to
shave maybe 400 to 500 grams from this
and so really what this turned into
doing as well is the gripper design and
integrating that with the control system
so it account for that center of mass
but if you remember back to our previous
slide with the old system is don't
reinvent the wheel is if we know the
stuff joint is very effective and very
and what it does mechanically is let's
go with what's known and create a
gripper which can be easily actuated to
actually pick up a plate and we know
it's rock solid and so will your
watching this video here is you'll
actually see this drone take off with
the same bike on camera systems and this
was on an mi t--'s lab working in
conjunction with career because they
were one of the SBIR award EES based
upon some of the MCAT specifications and
it's really been a fun project to see
here and what you'll see it is actually
picked this plate up take it back and
then put the plate back in and so if you
want to show up watch this video
you
you
you
and so what you saw there was a the
slight adjustment with the control
system for the center of gravity is when
I pick up the plate he saw pinched
slightly down and I'm gonna put the
plate home you saw it sort of raised its
arm and victory that I did it but what
it shows is with technology currently
available today is it's feasible that
you can use an autonomous vehicle to
move plates from point A to point B and
we know that this is actually very
preliminary and there's challenges such
as rotor wash but it introduces the
concept of autonomy of systems
communicating one another that were
never intended to which is really
exciting and just one last example is
what would this look like potentially if
we had multiple drones and a shared
environment this is showing dynamic
collision avoidance but really for a
hiker but screaming challenge we would
have fixed stations that these drones
would fly to but this is showing
conceptually rerouting so what you're
going to see here is the squares on the
ground and there's red green and blue or
where the drone is supposed to go the
circle is where the drone is suppose is
actually currently located and what
you'll see is the intersect as the
drones can dynamically avoid colliding
with one another as the circle meets up
at the square if you want to show this
video
don't be a demon Rosa
[Music]
and so what you're able to see from this
is not only can one drone actually do a
pick in place you can have several
drones working in tandem and actually
avoid collision there or technically
people and remember this is any
autonomous vehicle it could be a
land-based instrument is actually more
suitable towards lab environment as
opposed to a drone but it's really
possible and so really what we want to
show in this presentation is as you're
expanding your automation and you're
looking from where you currently are to
where you want to be is if you look at
devices from the component level and
then how that component impacts the
device and then how that device impacts
the overall system and then how that
distributed systems can actually work
together and then the possibility of
integrating these distributed systems is
there you can actually have the
potential for autonomous assays and so
if you imagine from this perspective if
we have our high throughput screening
system is one distributed system with
all peripheral devices and then we have
our selectee for example that's
generating cells is if it was capable of
sending event which is it which it is
when a plate is available and we can
integrate that with an overall
controlling architecture is that could
actually initiate a new assay on a
completely independent system if we have
some play transportation mechanism and
that's really geared towards what we're
shooting for eventually is this concept
of autonomous so we look at the
trajectory of automation over the years
it was a long time ago now that things
were computerized and then it went
through this step and where they're
actually automated and we're looking for
now from the both be sustainable
distributed but really the goal is once
again autonomous and we're not there yet
and there's plenty of work to do but
we're showing through some of the work
we're doing in n cats and with many more
collaborators and both partnerships and
SBIR contracts is we're really on the
track for some really exciting times and
we haven't even talked about the actual
data analysis piece which is a huge part
of this but a presentation all to itself
so with that I want
thank everyone for their time and
especially this is the complete team
effort at MCATs and none of this could
happen without all of these components
working together thank you very much
thank you Sam for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
first question is what are key
considerations to consider when
designing a high-throughput screening
process very first consideration and
this one really before you do anything
else is understand what you're even
trying to automate and what I mean by
that is typically when these systems go
off the rails is people try to have them
do too much and they end up designing
towards the very low use cases and
introduce complexity is what we try to
do is design something in a modular
fashion towards the most common approach
want to take so really a key
consideration is understand your process
that you're trying to automate don't
make a system trying to do too much or
especially don't design to the exception
but then also make sure you have
modularity and a key consideration is
make sure you complete control of the
software both from a perspective of
being able to monitor what it's doing
but also from a perspective actually
being able to schedule it and be able to
control it thank you
what should someone look for when
considering high-throughput screening
scheduling software in line with the
previous question is you should really
consider the capability once again to be
able to monitor and log every event
because it's hard to say when you know
an event will become important and you
might have an experimental design down
the road that you might want to track
something and if you don't have the
capability up front
it could really limit you so one of the
first step is make sure it has
monitoring and monitoring control
capabilities but even furthermore make
sure it has the ability to have
programmatic control meaning you can get
the scan
to do something programmatically from an
external application
many of the schedulers available both
commercial and open source these days
have that capability be it direct or
even there's you can do plenty of things
to gain scheduling software but a real
consideration especially when I shoot
towards more advanced automation and
more tricky experiments is having a very
fine level of programmatic control of
the scheduling software what direction
do you see going forward for
high-throughput screening systems I
think what we're seeing now is the days
of the monolithic larger system even the
ones that we have back to the early
2000s they're really they're still in
use and at certain in certain places but
I think they're going away
we're towards a more modular approach we
can actually split up your entire
process that maybe takes place on
several systems not just one so I think
it's a mixture of having this this
modular approach and also this this this
nimble approach so it can be
reconfigured you can still in the
libraries are still larger and larger
size but in many cases more focused
specific libraries but there's more
complex when you coming with assays and
so you want to make sure that if you
design a system you can keep up with
that actual additional complexity and
that's something that we're seeing again
cats and also some of our other folks
involved in this space are sharing some
of that those thoughts as well can we
have time for one more question
how practical is it really to consider
having a drone in a laboratory
environment not at all not at all in its
current state but what's what this is
shooting towards is this concept again
of autonomous and autonomous vehicles
are more and more prevalent they're
already heavily in use now and
especially in inventory and tracking
applications and this concept of being
able to actually do a pick in place you
know instead of just a monitoring type
event or taking an inventory is really
transformational so as it stands right
now it's not too practical but there is
a lot of work only on autonomous
vehicles not just drones will you
consider a land-based vehicle there's
actually some other groups actively
working in this space and a very
controlled
you can control the grooms by path or
very specific use it could have some
practicality but it's really about
pushing the technical boundaries to get
towards that goal of autonomous I'll
beyond just automation well thank you I
would like to once again thank Sam
Michael for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August
31st 2018 you'll receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye